from a financial strategist's point of
view how big a deal is artificial
intelligence going to be over the next
say 10 years well it's going to be huge
I wanted I want to distinguish something
about artificial intelligence
um artificial intelligence which really
means a pretty much machine learning
is tremendously advantageous in raising
productivity and doing things that are
more mundane
and on the other hand can be very
dangerous
um it's
um if something is done over and over
again repeatedly and the computer can
watch the patterns of that and that
could be anything from performing a
surgery it's done the same time way so
that the future
um will be like the past it can be
relied on and used pervasively in
excellent ways however if the future is
different from the past
um and it relies on those past
relationships it can be very dangerous
um because what one gets out of it as
Henry mentioned is
um equations without the understanding
of why those conclusions exist so in a
race to be uh effective there's a real
tendency to want to use artificial
intelligence on most things but there
may not be the same level of
understanding and so if the future is
different from the past in important
ways it can be very uh threatening